hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmfc control
ir.l2-3.6.1 establish an operational
incident handling capability for
organizational systems that includes
preparation detection analysis
containment recovery and user response
activities
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so what is this control really all
about
well my good friends in the Marines they
say the worst time to start planning a
good defense is when the bullets are
flying in your head yes this control is
all about being prepared having a
written and practice plan in place so
your entire team knows exactly what to
do when an attack happens now this
control also requires you to essentially
have a written incident response plan
okay so there's a big hint right there
about how to solve for it that will have
several key steps included in it the
idea is that if you know how to respond
the response will be faster more
effective and there is a chance at
actually limiting damage and having as
much having a much faster recovery from
the incident so let's dive into what the
assessors are looking for on this one
how we can make them happy so I will
warn you this one has got several
different assessment points there's
probably about seven or eight of them
we'll dive in the first one here
determine if an operational incident
handling capability is established so do
you have the capability to respond uh if
I was going to answer this we might have
a simple answer in the plan say
something like implemented see the
incident response policy and incident
response form note that there's two
parts of the capability there's how are
you going to sort of identify that there
was an issue and then how are you going
to resolve it and then what's the
procedure for all of that so this is
another one of those controls where
they're assessing on a bunch of
different points and surprise surprise
it's not so much your the answer in the
system security plan that they're
looking for it's giving me the backup
documentation which is why there's so
many assessment points so assessment
Point number two determine if the
operational incident handling capability
includes preparation so implemented CNC
response policy and instant response
form again they're going to look and see
how are you preparing uh for an incident
to happen now as we go through these
assessment points which will sort of
begin to realize is they're basically
outlining the the parts and portions of
an incident response plan so the cool
thing is if you don't have one these
assessment points will help you to write
one so third assessment Point determine
if the operational incident handling
capability includes detection so in your
plan are you do you have a mechanism for
detection Implement is the incident
response policy and incident response
form next determine if the operational
incident handling capability includes
analysis so again in your incident
response you need to have mechanisms in
place or steps in place to be able to
actually uh analyze what's going on with
that incident to determine what the
right next move is
so again steps in the plan if you will
so next we have determine if the
operational incident handling capability
includes containment so do we have some
methodology for containing the incident
and obviously limiting the damage again
all these answers will kind of be the
same that we're going to say hey go look
at our documentation in other words the
incident response policy uh incident
response plan however you want to phrase
it and then of course the incident
response form now to determine if the
operational incident handling capability
includes recovery this is implemented
CNC response policy and instant response
form again the idea here is do you have
steps in your plan for how to recover
from an incident final assessment Point
determine if the operational incident
handling capability includes user
response activities so what are your
users supposed to do and specifically
how are your users supposed to respond
in every step again go back to
documentation we'll hear instant
response plans and also the incident
response forms that people are filling
out when they're filing for an incident
and determine exactly how effective
those are and specifically what the user
responses should be and if those are
there you should be good to go but if
they're not because you don't have any
of these policies or if you're like so
many defense contractors out in there
who are just looking at this whole thing
going oh my goodness I'm throwing my
hands up in the air I don't know what to
do
um I'm gonna go have a beer then hey the
good news is here at on-call we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this D fars nist itar and
cmmc compliant stuff dropped in their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day and
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more content uh or more help our
compliance experts are always on call
for you you can visit cmmc
compliancecrets.com or check out the bio
below for links to get help right now if
you love the content we're putting out
here for you help us out with big thumbs
up on that like button and of course you
know what to do smash that subscribe
button because you know what they're
constantly changing things I just saw
the other day they brought out nist SP
800 171 revision three and again this
stuff changes all the time so Mash that
subscribe button uh and until the next
compliance tip my friend stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]